fast forward please the food looks
amazing
but the table management system is
chaotic with too many people involved it
would be so much better if just one
person took responsibility starters
mains desserts and then we have a little
appetizer tic basically the chef's can
see it from where he is and everybody up
here knows where they are up here I'm
not convinced despite all the waiting
staff those restaurants letting my
diners down
we went through a course yellow just
artichoke left us so it's just 1 hour 20
minutes with nothing in front of them
all these waiters are flying around no
starters what better than that
- dorri - bream is away now as time
ticks on everything started to get
muddled up which day would you want last
they were fall and the full scale of the
mess is only just becoming clear before
little over an hour and a half now our
starting wants to play with no stars
that way
unfortunately someone cost they are for
this song how can you have so many
management out there and they cross it
off and having said them yet huh they've
got more managers here they've got a
budget in Polish - keep going keep going
keep going with time running out fast
and some guests still not served I'm
starting to fear the worst
I say that's it 20 minutes ago chicken
sauce say me chicken sauce let's get out
three waiters guys passing
don't have someone help him - the ice
cream puts garnish on you know but then
I see the problem is she problem is have
given me that which is Table four and
Table six right sit timeout
two hours gone incredibly for the first
time in his competition and not all my
diners been fed two courses for a
restaurant this good it's embarrassing
do I want to be judged on a vicious
wozzles do I want to have that seven
front of me it's a no-brainer it's
beautiful I mean just stomach they can't
tell everybody how [ __ ] delicious
because it's got parts for two hours
the only comfort for Colin is the fact
that the diners that did receive their
food loved it it was well worth waiting
for
what we're fighting for we did wait a
little longer than expected and when it
can yeah well end of service and time
for me to tell winter him feels whether
I thought things were bomb or not
big test feedback for the dining room
service claustrophobic that's why they
pulled some of the waiters out and get
rid of some of the drapes think you know
that kind of pizza stayed you winching
them fields s service can feedback back
from the customs their experience the
service being to foster phobia she
listens you've nor it ignore it
are you peril if my diners felt that
your service was claustrophobic please
listen to it because this is valuable
information we're looking for the best
restaurant in Britain not just the best
food but the best service and it goes
hand in glove the customers loved the
food which was great news sadly then get
Charles the taste at all because we ran
out of time don't worry about the
foo-foo I think you guys try too hard
and I just think you guys just need to
chill a minute you match the service
with a level of a sense of detail on the
food you've got something unique here